play utah up by three mitchell the cross  mitchell the jumper off the rim  rebounded by rondo  la down by three ten seconds left  leonard for george back for leonard  ball fake running out of time morris  one dribble block and that'll do it  that's game and it ends on a french  rejection  holds on and takes game one  at home incredible  defensive display on that last  possession  they were in scramble mode very  disciplined didn't overreact to pump  fakes  okay go bear here avoids the contact  stays with it and the long arm of the  law delivers for the jazz once again  rudy gobert the two-time defensive  player of the year  and he can single-handedly anchor your  defense in the biggest moment  donovan mitchell's family enjoying  a jazz win in a tight one  game one of the western conference semis  that was a treat that was one  heck of a ball game great intensity and  how about the fight  of the jazz in that second half  the jazz get it done in the series  opener